here with more reactions to today's
hearing Texas senator Ted Cruz senator
good to see you what we've learned is
this was all planned all orchestrated
that a big call labor day first they
think thought about walking out then
they said we'll do this I don't think it
hurts in any way for the American people
to see the left for who they are Sean I
think that's exactly right I think
yesterday and today we're both really
good days there were good days for the
country they were good days for Brett
Kavanaugh in two days of hearings on the
Judiciary Committee the Democrats have
not laid a single glove on Brett
Kavanaugh there's been a lot of
screaming there's been a lot of
protesting there's been a lot of anger
and it's really the reflection of the
incredible rage and fury we're seeing on
the far left and you're right by all
appearances these protests are closely
coordinated with the Democratic senators
indeed yesterday Senator John Kennedy
asked about this conference call between
Democratic senators in the protest to
disrupt the hearings and and Dick Durbin
the Democrat from Illinois he jumped in
and said yep we had a conference call
and and he didn't dispute that it was a
coordinated effort you know yesterday 70
people were arrested but at the end of
the day the rage the anger they're
having they haven't been able to give
even a single argument that is going to
derail this not nomination no Democrat
is disputed that Brett Kavanaugh is
qualified to serve on the Supreme Court
and they're just really expressing the
rage of the far left to Donald Trump
they're mad that Trump won in 2016 and
Hillary Clinton lost and I think come
October we're going to see judge
Kavanaugh become justice Cavanaugh and
that's a great victory for every one of
us who cares about the Constitution and
the Bill of Rights and our fundamental
liberties you know I'm watching I'm
reading The Washington Post tonight and
as a result of this this anonymous
frankly gutless disloyal New York Times
peeps but they're actually talking about
the sleeper cells have awoken of the
resistance and I'm thinking there's
something extraordinarily dangerous if
unelected swamp creatures think that
they have the authority to undermine the
president from within what if the
president's talking about national
security if he's talking about maybe
going to war
what if he's talking about intelligence
sources methods while the media is
celebrating tonight I'm thinking there's
a great danger that exists right well
look it at one level this is nothing new
with every Republican administration
there are Democrats that are burrowed
within the administration that have
fought against good and positive policy
for the country at another level it has
been much much worse under the trump
administration we've seen the deep state
we've seen Democrats coming out of the
Obama administration deeply politicized
who are fighting the president in every
front you know you know in many ways
it's remarkable the victories we've seen
we've seen a historic tax cut the
biggest tax cut in a generation we've
seen regulatory reform job-killing
regulations pulled back we've seen the
Obama care individual mandate repealed
as you know I led the fight to make that
happen in the Senate nobody thought we'd
get it done we got it done and and we've
seen on judges an enormous victory not
only neo Gorsuch but we're getting ready
to have Brett Cavanaugh and we've got
principled constitutionalists up and
down the federal bench there are people
throughout the administration burrowed
in that are fighting against all of that
but the American people are seeing the
results of these victories we're seeing
it an incredible job growth and economic
growth it's interesting because you had
a tough primary with with the President
and really you have emerged as one of
the strongest allies in advancing every
part of what I would argue is his
conservative agenda and the president
says it I think he's doing a big arena
maybe the biggest in taxes I read for
you tell us about how that relationship
has evolved in and how I know for a fact
how much he's relying on you and the son
yeah well the president I have worked
hand-in-hand since since the day was
elected we obviously had a vigorous
primary in 2016 it was hard-fought but
the primary is over and as you know the
week after the general election in 2016
I got on a plane I flew to New York City
and I spent four and a half hours with
the president his senior team I said mr.
president this is an historic
opportunity it is rare to have control
of the White House in both houses of
Congress we can't blow it and I think
the four big domestic priorities were
tax cuts regulatory reform Oh
Obamacare and judges and I told him that
day I said I want to do everything
humanly possible to leave the fight in
the Senate to deliver on our promises
and I got to say that level we're doing
it is enormous and let me just finally
say to your viewers go to Ted Cruz org
Ted Cruz org Ted Cruz org we got a big
fight in the Senate we're being
outraised
two-to-one we need your help well
senator I know you've been a strong
conservative a strict constitutionalists
all throughout your career in spite of
what the media is praying for I know the
people of Texas appreciate what you're
doing there thank you so much for being
with us thank you Shawn take care